Der schnelle Imbiss für zwischendurch.
Mit Zwiebeln, geschnitten
oder in einem Stück: die Currywurst.
Es gibt sie mit Pommes oder
mit einem Brötchen.
Ein Muss, is’ eine Legende.
Sehr gut!
Nach ’ner langen Shopping-Tour
braucht man was zur Stärkung,
und da lieb ich Currywurst
mit Pommes. Das ist ideal.
Currywurst geht immer.
Der Imbiss „Kudamm 195“ in
Berlin-Charlottenburg:
Die Zubereitung geht schnell.
Schneiden und würzen, dann Ketchup oder
eine scharfe Spezialsauce darübergeben.
Es wird gebraten, ständig gedreht.
Täglich frisches Fett muss sein, wo
die Wurst drin gebraten wird.
Was fürn Fett, ist wieder ein Geheimnis.
Jeder macht es anders.
Wir haben unseres.
An die 500 Imbissbuden gibt es in Berlin.
Rund 600.000 Currywürste im Jahr
gehen allein an diesem Stand
im Stadtteil Kreuzberg über die Theke.
Die Currywurst besteht hier
aus Schweinefleisch.
Es gibt sie mit Darm und
– eine Berliner Variante – ohne Darm.
Berlin schläft ja nich’. In Berlin is’
immer wat los.
Ob dat nun die Handwerker sin’,
die Touristen.
Am, grad am Wochenende meine
Kollegen bis morgens um fünfe,
manchmal müssen sie bis halb
sechse, sechse verkaufen.
Und wenn sie dann am Saubermachen
sin’, kommen die Leute noch rin
und sagen um halb sieben:
Was denn, schon alles Feierabend?
Wir haben Hunger. Wir haben Hunger.
Das ist zwar nicht das gesündeste
Essen, aber es schmeckt,
und wir sind im Urlaub,
also warum nicht?
Die Berlinerin Herta Heuwer gilt
als Erfinderin der Currywurst.
Sie will als Erste mit Ketchup, Currypulver
und Worcestershiresauce
experimentiert haben.
Ihre Sauce ließ sie 1959 patentieren.
Das dokumentiert das Deutsche
Currywurstmuseum in Berlin.
Sie mischte im September 1949
verschiedene Zutaten zusammen
und kreierte die Currywurst.
Sie nannte ihren Verkaufsstand auch
die erste Currywurstbraterei der Welt.
Und so wird ihr die Erfindungsgeschichte
eigentlich hier in Berlin auch zugesagt.
Aber auch das Ruhrgebiet und Hamburg
beanspruchen,
die Currywurst erfunden zu haben.
Die Zubereitung variiert regional.
So wurde der Hamburger Edelimbiss
„Curryqueen“
schon mehrfach im Gourmetführer
„Gault Millau“ erwähnt.
Hochwertiges Fleisch vom Büffel oder
auch Kobe-Rind wird hier fettarm gegrillt.
Die Beilagen: grüner Salat oder
hausgemachter Kartoffelsalat.
Den Curry zum Würzen können sich
die Kunden selber aussuchen.
Wir haben sieben verschiedene Currys
von ganz mild bis extrem scharf.
Aber uns geht‘s natürlich viel mehr um
die Aromen,
weniger um die Schärfegrade.
Es gibt eins mit Hibiskusblüte,
was dann wirklich lilafarben is’.
Das is’ ganz toll, das essen
Kinder auch gerne,
weil das ganz mild is’ und schön aussieht.
Dann gibt’s eins mit Vanille,
es gibt eins mit Zitronengras.
Dann gibt's so ’n ganz klassisches
Curry mit Knoblauch-Ingwer.
Im Berliner Stadtteil Prenzlauer Berg
ist man da nicht so wählerisch.
An Konnopkes Traditionsimbiss
begann schon 1960
– im damaligen Ost-Berlin
– das Geschäft mit der Currywurst.
Den Fleischhappen vom Pappteller
probierten hier auch
Prominente wie US-Star Liza Minelli.
Zu Ostzeiten gab es ja nur Tomatenmark,
Tomatenpüree, Tomatenpaste,
was man zugeteilt bekommen hat,
und da ham wir uns von drüben
'ne Flasche Ketchup gekauft
und dann ham wir so lange probiert,
bis wir diesen Geschmack raushatten.
Ein Rezept, das seit
Jahrzehnten gut ankommt:
Das Fleisch ist super bei Konnopke,
und ich finde, das auch wichtig,
also gerade bei ’ner Currywurst,
dann schmeckt sie auch richtig gut.
Ob in Berlin, Hamburg oder im Ruhrgebiet:
Die Currywurst zählt in Deutschland
zu den kulinarischen Klassikern.